[Musica]
[Applauso]
quello che oggi vi voglio raccontare non
è soltanto un'ipotesi
quello che oggi sono qui a raccontarvi è
storia è una storia difficile la storia
tra la convivenza tra gli alberi e noi
esseri umani che dobbiamo condividere un
pianeta un pianeta che in questo momento
soffre e soffre soprattutto a causa
nostra
oggi ci sono tremila miliardi di alberi
sulla terra
noi siamo soltanto 7,5 significa che
abbiamo circa 400 alberi a testa più o
meno ora con la deforestazione con l'uso
del suolo per fare le culture intensive
piuttosto che per andare a cercare
minerali a cercare risorse noi oggi
perdiamo 20 miliardi di alberi all'anno
a fronte solo di 5 al 5 miliardi di
alberi piantati ogni anno significa che
mediamente perdiamo 15 miliardi di
alberi ogni anno sono due alberi a testa
sembrano tanti no non lo sono
sono duecento anni a questo ritmo prima
che venga abbattuto l'ultimo albero
ma c'è di più perché potremmo fermarci
fermarci qui sarebbe già abbastanza
abbastanza grave ma facciamo un altro
danno
noi produciamo nidi ride carbonica e non
solo respirando la produciamo
spostandoci la produciamo con le nostre
industrie la produciamo per quasi tutto
quello che facciamo è solo quattro
tonnellate a testa ogni anno che entrano
in atmosfera purtroppo per noi gli
alberi riescono a
trarre a sequestrare dall'atmosfera
soltanto 15 chili di anidride carbonica
ogni anno significa che a noi per
riuscire a sopperire a al danno che
facciamo noi con le nostre attività
antropiche servono addirittura 350
alberi per ognuno di noi non sono tanti
perché significa che abbiamo soltanto 50
alberi di margine e ai due all'anno in
meno che vedevamo prima purtroppo sono
solo 25 anni ora in questo nostro
piccolo esercizio matematico in realtà
abbiamo dimenticato un'altra grande
fonte di sottrazione di anidride
carbonica che sono gli oceani gli oceani
contribuiscono per il 50 per cento a
sequestrare l'anidride carbonica che noi
mettiamo in atmosfera si è un'ottima
notizia
stiamo però dimenticando all'interno dei
nostri conticini qua fatti tra noi un
altro grosso fattore non siamo soli non
siamo soli perché noi abbiamo tutta una
terra di cui dovevamo essere custodi
altre piante animali
prima si diceva che perdiamo mille
specie ogni anno mille specie che
appunto sono messo milioni di anni per
arrivare a noi e con il nostro impatto
noi le stiamo distruggendo forse non era
proprio questo che veniva inteso dalla
genesi quando diceva che dovevamo
dominare i pesci del mare e gli uccelli
del cielo
non era questo perché poco dopo ci dice
che dobbiamo essere custodi di questo
giardino in cui siamo inseriti
ecco se noi andiamo a vedere quello che
siamo in biomassa
noi siamo lo 0,1 niente tutti gli
animali sono il 2,7 per cento
le piante addirittura piante tra alberi
e vegetali bassi
sono 97,3 noi con il nostro 0,01
influenziamo la vita di tutti gli altri
è una responsabilità enorme per noi
siamo responsabili di questa terra
confuso diceva che il momento migliore
per piantare un albero e vent'anni fa e
lo prendo a posto adesso perché appunto
era vent'anni fa il momento buono il
secondo nel momento migliore e adesso ed
è adesso perché non abbiamo più tempo
non abbiamo più tempo perché se ci
guardiamo intorno
quello che vi ho raccontato la storia e
storie perché l'anidride carbonica sta
aumentando non è costante
l'abbiamo già passato quel punto siamo
già oltre
è per questo che quello che voglio
chiedervi oggi e ve lo chiedo con il
cuore in mano su uno di voi e di darmi
una mano a cambiare le cose nella gag
che ognuno di voi oggi ha trovato sulla
sua sedia ho messo un sacchetto
contenente dei semi ci sono semi di
piante diverse io vi chiedo di darmi una
mano e di piantarli piantarli nel posto
giusto piantarli dove possano diventare
degli alberi forti grandi che possono
aiutarci a dare un futuro non a me non a
voi ma a chi amate ai nostri figli ai
nostri nipoti perché questo è il nostro
compito è custodirla per poterla portare
intatta alle generazioni che verranno
grazie
[Applauso]